foreign
today is an important moment in the
history of the labor party
it's taken many many months of hard work
and humility to get here
it's meant rebuilding trust not just
with the Jewish community
but with all those who were rightly
appalled by the culture of the party and
the previous leadership
when I became leader I said I would turn
labor around and give it back to the
British people
and the most important and Urgent part
of that was in tearing out anti-Semitism
by its roots
anti-Semitism isn't evil
and no political party that cultivates
it deserves to hold power
I said from the start that we would be
judged not on our own terms
but by the return of those who felt they
could no longer support us
step on that Journey was to accept the
findings of the equality and Human
Rights Commission
but it was deeper than that because we
also had to make clear that there was no
space for anyone who didn't do the same
that is as true today as it was then
let me be very clear
those who seek to blame others or
downplay what happened in our party are
themselves part of the problem and we
will have zero patience or tolerance of
that
having accepted the commission's report
the onus was then on us to begin to
right the wrongs of the past
I'm proud to lead a party in a team that
have worked tirelessly to do so and it
is as a result of that work that I'm
speaking here today
but while it is an important moment
it is not one for celebration
it is one for reflection
on how a party that has always prided
itself on anti-racism
on its commitment to equality its belief
in a better fairer Britain
could have fallen so far as to betray
its own principles as well as the
principles of the country
this is also a moment
to apologize once again
to all those who were hurt to all those
who were let down to all those driven
out of our party who no longer felt it
was their home who suffered the most
appalling abuse
today on behalf of the entire labor
party
I say sorry
what you've been through can never be
undone
apologies alone cannot make it right
but just as I promised to take this
issue head on
today I make you a number of further
promises
firstly that under my leadership there
will be Zero Tolerance of anti-Semitism
or racism or discrimination of any kind
and secondly that every day I will work
ceaselessly to bring this party back to
the British people
be no doubt
the job of restoring labor is not
complete not even close
I don't see today's announcement as the
end of the road
I see it as a signpost that we're
heading in the right direction
I feel humbled when I think of all those
who tirelessly dedicated themselves to
getting labor back on track
all those inside and outside the party
who've made it their mission to restore
renew and rebuild labor on behalf of the
country
it's thanks to them
that we can say firmly proudly
confidently
the labor party has changed
not because it was convenient to do so
not by fiddling around the edges
not just until the next person to lead
the party comes along
but permanently fundamentally
irrevocably
we have changed
from a party that looked inward to a
party that meets the public gays
from a party of Dogma to a party of
patriotism
from a party of protest
to a party of Public Service
change is never easy
and I understand that some people won't
like the changes that we've made
but I say this with all candor
the labor party is unrecognizable from
2019 and it will never go back
it will never again be a party captured
by narrow interest it will never again
lose sight of its purpose or its morals
and it will never again be brought to
its knees by racism or bigotry
if you don't like that
if you don't like the changes that we've
made
I say
the door is open and you can leave
but to all those who could see we've
changed for the better
and are excited about doing even more
to all those who dream of a Britain that
is fairer Greener more dynamic
to all those who want to make this great
country greater still I say
the door is open
come in
make us your home again
working together
I believe we can do great things for our
country
I believe we can be a force for good
and that starts today
no one knows better for me that there is
much still to do
that is why my third promise to you
today
is that I will not rest for a moment
until the job of changing the labor
party for the better and then the job of
changing our country for the better are
complete
thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much we're going to take
some questions now from the media and I
think Alex from BBC was starting with
you
thank you very much secure Alex Forsyth
BBC News you've talked today about how
the labor party on your watch has
changed can you say categorically
whether or not the former leader Jeremy
corbyn will stand for labor at the next
election
let me be very clear about that
Jeremy corbyn will not stand for labor
at the next general election as a labor
Party candidate what I said about the
party changing I meant and we are not
going back and that is why Jeremy corbyn
will not stand as a labor candidate at
the next general election thank you Alex
I think Marie were coming to you Sky
News
news
um you served under Jeremy corbyn in his
shadow cabinet and today we've had the
campaign against anti-Semitism come out
and say that they still don't think
they've had enough investigative
essentially disciplinary investigations
into anti-Semitism against more than 12
MPS
don't you think this undermines your
commitment to Jewish people and Jewish
voters that you're taking this seriously
well thank you for that question
um I think and I hope that my actions
over the last two to three years have
made it absolutely clear that my
commitment is to tear anti-Semitism out
of this party by the roots that was the
first thing I said as leader of the
labor party that's why we've taken the
action that we've done that's why I am
pleased today that the commission has
said that they're confident in the plan
that we have put forward but look as I
said a moment ago this is not the end of
the road this is just a signpost and we
must be as robust as we go forward as
we've been until now and whatever cases
and allegations are put to us we will
take the same robust approach today is
an important day but it's certainly not
the end of the road in relation to that
thank you Harry
ITV good morning Adam
Harry Horton from ICB news uh you served
under Jeremy corbyn in his shadow
cabinet when you were serving into
Jeremy corbyn could you not see
anti-Semitism spreading throughout the
party and if you if you could why didn't
you do more to speak out about it well
Harry thank you for that question
um as you know it's a matter of record
that on antisemitism I challenged the
previous leader both in the shadow
cabinet and publicly on that
um and it's absolutely clear that the
labor party lost its way and that's why
I knew that my first Duty as leader of
the labor party was to change the labor
party and to tear anti-Semitism out
that's why on my acceptance speech I
made an apology on behalf of the labor
party I made that my commitment and what
I asked of all those that were affected
was the opportunity to be given the
space to do what I needed to do and to
be judged by my actions and I'm grateful
to all of those who gave me that space
and are now judging me on my actions
thank you Harry Lee
Lee Hopkins and Jewish news yeah
um are you today promising you will take
action against any MP any counselor any
member in the party who denies
anti-Semitism who uses the phrase Purge
of socialism to excuse anti-Semitism are
you pledging action against it Lee thank
you very much for that question I hope
I've made it clear this morning and
previously that all those that deny
um the is a problem there was a problem
of anti-Semitism all those that pretend
it was exaggerated are part of the
problem themselves and will be dealt
with under the rules of the labor party
because it's very important that we are
robust in relation to
um those views that this was all somehow
exaggerated
and that the extent has been
disproportionately blown out I don't
accept that and I don't accept that has
a place in our labor party thank you Lee
and Ben from the Jewish Chronicle please
good morning hi so it seems this is a
really big day for the labor party it
seems the upper echelons are in the
right place and the HRC is happy with
the progress but as alluded to by Marie
Van derzilla the board of deputies there
are still issues at the local level with
counselors and party officials
um JC revealed just yesterday A Party
official who had been local party
official had been posting you know
extremely questionable content for many
many years up until most recently so you
know are you confident that issues are
being addressed at the local level and
how can you reassure Jewish people who
want to get involved in local Party
politics that they will be safe to do so
thank you well uh Ben thank you for that
question the the fight against
anti-Semitism is never over
um and that's why it's so important that
I make it clear today that
um of course it's an important day for
the labor party that the Commissioners
decided that our plan has been operated
and they're content with it but it
doesn't mean the fight against
anti-Semitism is over anywhere uh in any
political party including my political
party and we will continue with the same
robust approach because the changes that
we've put in place are fundamental
they're substantial the labor party has
changed and that and the commission
would not have signed off today if they
didn't think it was fundamental and
substantial and so wherever there is
anti-Semitism we will chase it down and
we will deal with it in the same robust
way as we've done over the last two to
three years thank you and I think we
just about got time for Theo from LBC
Theo Ashford I'll be saying thanks for
taking my questions uh secure at the
beginning of your statement you said
that under Jeremy corbyn labor
cultivated uh anti-Semitism that would
suggest that there may have been a
political intention to allow a culture
of anti-Semitism to Foster for perhaps
political ends do you think that's the
case and I think everybody in this room
could testify to the fact that there is
still anti-Semitism is still prevalent
in society and how much responsibility
do you think Jeremy corbyn his
leadership of the labor party Bears
responsibility for that well uh yeah
thank you for that question
um I I think that the work against
anti-Semitism is never over
um it was absolutely clear to me when I
took over as leader and labor party that
we had to change the labor party and we
had to start with anti-Semitism and
that's why as leader and labor party in
my acceptance speech I apologize for
what had gone before and that's why I
said what I said this morning and I
stand by there those words but look you
know very very important that we're
clear that
um this is a signpost that we are making
progress a signpost that the actions
we've taken over the last two three
years are the right actions
um but um it would be a complete mistake
in my view to think that now somehow the
job is done it is never done we must
fight anti-Semitism wherever we find it
every day as a political party every day
as as individuals thank you Theo and uh
al-alitha from the guardian thank you
thank you Elita Addy from the guardian
if you are set on ensuring that the
labor party will be one not of protest
but for the quality will you this
morning prescribe the momentum group
that has long supported Jeremy corbyn or
at least put them on notice this morning
well look I have many powers and duties
and responsibilities in the labor party
but that one is not uh for me I'm afraid
but look whatever
um you know group or individual in the
labor party I think the message from
this morning couldn't be clearer
um this is an important day
um it's a day of reflection
the change that we've brought about is
substantial and it is permanent the
labor party has changed and if there's
anyone in the labor party
um that doesn't like that change then my
message them is very clear this morning
the door is open and you can leave
thank you very much thank you
thank you